[Music]
uh this is true I would never lie I went
to the beach last night we live in Los
Angeles and here it is uh November and I
went to the beach last night I love the
beach at night off hour Beach evening
Beach just me walking on just me and
the every once in a while a weirdo
dumping a body you know just that's what
I like low stress Beach I actually uh I
took a Vine I wanted to show you this I
took a Vine of a rock relaxing at the
beach would you like to see my Vine that
I shot the let's look at a Vine that I
shot going
on yeah right when he started singing
the nothing much going on song he
started drowning it's really what are
the chances I got a few stairs for uh
gargling and screaming at the beach
that's
true I'll tell you what I don't like
about the beach I don't like uh Peak
Beach I don't like Saturday you know
peak hour five friends pressure full day
at the beach you know what I'm talking
about here's my impression of a full day
at the beach you're like all right I got
my chair I got my book my umbrella my
sunglasses I'm lathered up in
sunblock let's get the out of
here that's it all that prep for like 30
seconds of nothing and then an urgent
need to leave but you can't you have to
stay you have to stay to make it work it
you brought all of this stuff so much
stuff in fact that's where I think we
got the first beach houses people are
just like well we brought
everything let's stay let's just build
our house on the sand did Jesus say
anything about
that weird Bible riff that was not
planned you're not going to see a lot of
late night host throwing in an unplanned
Jesus
riff but you're welcome Mom I finally
did something you like on the
show thank you yeah that's worth
applauding I feel like I feel like you
have to bring everything you own to the
beach because otherwise there's nothing
to do there's nothing to do basically
being at the beach sitting at the beach
all day is like volunteering to be
Shipwrecked you know what I mean that's
your your plan for your Saturday is just
pretending Your Vessel smashed upon the
Rocks you know there's nothing to do
when one of the activities at the beach
is bury
me that's like one of the choice what do
you want to do I don't know put me in a
hole cover me with an almost lethal
amount of
Earth now that's a
Saturday if you did that at the park
that's a felony but at the beach it's
like take a photo give me
boobs then you're just stuck there cold
and trapped under sand boobs just
watching
helplessly as a seagull steals your car
keys H
Elantra by the way seagulls can we agree
the worst
Birds I'll take a pigeon a crow any day
over a seagull they're like the bird
version of new money does
that does that Mak sense they live at
the beach they got the ocean view but
they're like I eat hot dogs and garbage
I got here cuz of a quick pick you know
like bait it new money
bird and if you're
not if you're not playing in the sand
the only other activity at the beach is
actually going into the ocean the ocean
that bowl of liquid
nightmares think about it sharks squids
jellyfish it's literally filled with
monsters it's like swimming through
Mario
Brothers
but completely
real it's there now while we're here now
it's there now these even the animals
that aren't dangerous are still
disgusting you ever just wait in and
you're like what what what was
that someone's like relax it was just a
SE cucumber oh okay just felt like the
inside of an eair got loose and went for
a
dip that's fine I'm glad we're here then
crabs crabs sorry those are real crabs
sea crabs on the beach exist and are
terrifying I'm just saying if crabs
existed on the land like if you saw them
loose like pigeons we wouldn't be here
right now we would all be assembled in
some sort of posy with torches and
pitchforks just like wondering how we
could rid the Earth of these sidewalking
land
demons that's all we would be doing but
because they're in the ocean for some
reason if it's in the water we're fine
with it but they're terrifying they're
like little hard shell dinosaurs they
got those Predator
mouths I'm talking about the really the
Predator has a crab mouth
but in my you know up here the Predator
comes first they got Pinchers crabs with
pinchers they look like little
Italians I'm just saying they look like
tiny Italians making a deal like
oh oh I got a great guy get you price on
Sand oh
my I feel you backing away on the
Italian voice I don't know why we all
went along with Sebastian and the Little
Mermaid just like everything's better
down with it's wetter but this is
offensive how did how did that get by
the sensors by the way a crab telling a
bikini clad young girl everything's
better down where it's
wet no one at Disney was like
ah this is extremely
up before we give this to the small ones
shouldn't we no I'll show myself
[Music]
out